accessibility at Dudley park aquatic
center has been given a lift with
installation of a new western change
table in the facilities accessible
changing rooms the
twenty-thousand-dollar equipment is
designed to allow pull users with
limited mobility to move more easily
between shower equipment toilet and
their wheelchair that means these are
accessibility to what's available for
everybody else so if you want to come
for a swim you can come to us one the
new motorized change table can also be
used for showering its height adjustable
and has a rail for safety children
giggling nancy has to be changed on the
floor previously but now with what the
be they can go on to the beach and
they've got the hand grabbed a safety
valve to prevent them from form we have
a situation where those who had excess
issues were having to change in a
semi-public area and it just wasn't an
equitable situation so providing this
facility and an area that can be closed
off and become private is absolutely
essential in our view to equality rex's
the center also has a poolside hydrology
and a dedicated which wheelchair which
allows wheelchair users to use ramp
access to better enjoy the pool
councillor peter ellen's is this is a
result of the council's ongoing
dedication towards ensuring the region's
public facilities are enjoyed by all
residents for example we're looking at
our camping grounds and our district and
wanting to ensure that any review of
those camping grounds deals with access
issues which might have been over up
from the park anjel expects that the
newly improved changing room will be use
of the pools increase from those with
accessibility requirements it was the
goal to unless it's more accessible for
everybody so everybody in the community
is the same access the same facility
that do the same thing